in his capsule goodbye the notion of
partial derivatives and bleachers then
an automatic learning what will
to interest us is to have
information on variations of
function but what to do and functions
who not only depend on one
argument x but several arguments
in fact what will interest us these
two to study there and exploit from
information about the relationship between the
loss of an algorithm and with respect to
these settings actually they these
settings will have several
a bit like in the tax collector we have
all a weight vector w that
correspond to all the parameters of the
collector
then in what if what we need
it's partial derivatives for
get information on the
variation of a function but by
report to each of his arguments to
each of these input variables so
the partial dlv is actually drifting
and but applied to a function where we go
consider that we will consider
only variable at a time and all the
other variables will be considered
as being constant here we have the body
special two input variables of a
function for a function that two
only arguments and drift and
partial of this function f ii x2 y
compared to x in a derby that
partial because we are interested in
derives a report to a single argument that
is going to be the limit of a gap that tends
to zero delta gap where we
is interested in f2 x + delta and y - f2 x /
the size of the delta team and the
same way if we are interested in drifting
and partial of fgx compared to f2
xy sorry about y only
have exactly the same definition but
where the gap is going to be added to y rather
that be added to x ok so that's
really finally there from the definition
of the hervé applied in the tale of
several variables
elop because
we talk about partial derivatives because
we are interested in variations
associated with a single variable so
it's partial in relation to a variable
given we will consider that others
variables are actually constant
when we do our innovation then
take things a little more concretely
let's do some examples
but I do not know a function f2 xy
which corresponds to aix squared / mixing
what if the partial derivatives of f2
xy compared to x it's going to be tight
correspond to drifting and
this expression there too explore / y
but where we will treat it like a
constant
so if we drift and two ex
traoré / a constant is actually the
beginning of his versus x the drift and
of a function once a constant that's
the constant times the derivative of the
function so in this case it would have
one on a Greek times the last two
ex square with respect to xp the drift and
of the ex-quarter and compared to x and 2x
so we'll see 2 x / y mixing bousquet
of the derivative of f2 x and y with respect to
there only received to explore how
consider as a constant one
consider x as a constant so
explore is also a constant by
report by will and in this case we will
see the drift and a constant / y
so that's going to be the constant for the
derby 2-1 on y the derivative of one on y
it's less safe, so we'll see
- ex square / there is when we made here
have applied the procedure to calculate
a derivative my entry txcom and at a
constant then were there in this case
if not a barrier of interest
a second example let's imagine that I
a function that depend on a vector
x so existence convectors with
the element x1 x2 and x3 hockey and the
imagine that I want to calculate the
hervé this function that takes
an input vector but with respect to
a single variable
in this case also x1 and well what are we going
do is we are going to treat x2 and x3
as being constants and so that
is equivalent to doing drifting and a
function f2 ixquick it's a scalar where
we would have the exponential two ex that is
the exponential of elections so I
loaded x factor x then in fact I
changed the numerator here that depends
dexter for a constant so to your
the experience he dexter then ben saada
is actually the other part that depends
other variables but that I'm dealing with
like soap constants x2 x3 so
lower the head experience x 2 more
the exponential of ex 3 when in front
and we're going to drift and that
expression there in relation to x we're going
treat all the other terms as
being findings so I have my function
which depends on a single school problem then
if I do the top derivative on space
2 x + b is the equivalent of doing the
drift is so finally I read it derived
up on the thoughts of the explosive
and compared to x so what I have
done here is that I put all my
function next to the derived operator
rather than putting it here just for
that the expression evening is easier
to watch
so that's a notation that often
used to simplify a little bit on
just wants to put the derivative operator
various dvx to the left of the expression whose
we hope we do not make it
drift and that expression there by
report to x
so we have a constant time a
function of x so that was if I will be
sunrise
constant sometimes the function that 1 on
experience it explosives and my
time I do I can drift
is one on my function here certainly
equal to - 1 on my square function of which
genre - o on the explosive experience
and squared times drift and what
remains to know the experiment she explodes
b the derivative of the experience of the ex
more b I can do is derived from
the yale experience of x factor
the exponential 2x plus drift and of
babies report to xv is a constant
so it's zero so I have left
only the 2x exponential we
find here
so my students xperia x10 drift -
offers a hendrix experience divides the
respect by yale experience of explodes
drunk and so finally I'm
ready to take my expression for excess
for b and replaced it with what
really corresponds to know his lands
experiential ii x2 qpc the experience and
mx2 plus the experience of the former 3 then
equivalent error replaced by the value
original which was x1
which means that the expo the derivatives
partial of f2 x compared to
first elements of the fixed vector by
relation to xp is sometimes the experience
he of x so if I replace c -
expanding guides twice
ldx experience 1 / exploration is
explosive and squared if I replace
the experiential one of x1 which is a
hendrix experience here most beautiful feat
62.7 france yale ii x3 alone to
quarters
third example let's take the same
function but now we will do the
deliberation the partial drift by
report to x2 the second element of x
men years that if because we have two
in the numerator the numerator repent
constant with the experience he of x but
we will still have b & b in this case
maybe going exponential of ex in
plus the experience and alex three so the
terms that do not depend on and kz2
so we drift and fgx that goes
here space and dx10 by experience it
expels b so we actually have the dlv of
a function of x / another function
of x that means we have the derivative of
the last function of the xth in the numerator
expanse of experts in paris xx 1 on
the experience he expels b - the
numerator / denominator squared
times the derivative of the denominator which
the experience of the express b derby
experience nfc experience and experience
1 on the experience he expels b that we
found here - the exponential of xxx
the dlv of that here the excerpt from
experience and explosives
because it's a consistency the dfb not
like it's zero stays all the drift
of expansion x versus x which is
experience and aix so in two times
by ac / dc
in fact I could have removed that I
know how to write expansible x squared /
the term here who has the experience and of
the express bu squared is still a
times well all that was terms
that we internship for finally the
replace with the original expression or
b will become the experience he 1.7 times
that of three ex will become external
what gives me
the expression here so in the examples
in fact what I did what I
started by identifying what is that
was a constant with respect to
variable so for which I was doing
there of partial hervé then the variable which
interested me in what I
doing
the dlv character replaced by x i
might not do that explicitly
and then just implicitly derived pharma
partial then simply treat
all the other variables that are not
released from which I am doing
derivatives as constants I have
just made an example here for
explicitly I replaced all
terms which which was constant by
report to me yable by see
which I was doing partial hervé
I replaced them with terms like
a and b that I often use as
constant just to reinforce the fact
that I treat them as constants
but it's not obliged to always
identify the constants of the replaced
by terms like alp to do the
partial derivatives it's just for
illustrate the fact that they are treated
in deflation as findings
now with the notion derived
partial
we will be able to introduce a rule the
rule of chain derivatives that go into
allows us to calculate
derivatives on arbitrary expressions
we would have convictions of
forgiveness combinations arbitrarily
function complex so we promised
than that which is a function f 2 x
that we can write as being calculated at
from an intermediate function j2x
and when if drift and f2 xperia
x1 can always be calculated as
being the drift and 2.6 relative to my
intermediate function j2x times the der
wiel of gdx by device you did that
we are already familiar with that we saw by
example if I want to calculate the drift and
of the nancial exhibition of an af function
x or if I want to calculate that in relation to
xbc actually equals the drift and of
the expo did not sky f2 x compared to
Africa what is to be
exponential dream of x times the
drift and f2 x para para x ok so we
is already doing well in co des
examples of this rule
more general that is true for anyone
what function and so it's really
a more general formulation of some
thing for the job
now what he new is also
the rule of chain diversion or
do our function of x is expressed
by is expressed from results
intermediates of more than one result
intermediate geii 2 x and in this case
also the drift and 6 relative to x
we will be able to write it as a sum
especially the intermediate results of
the derivative of f2 x with respect to j 2 x
so here it's really a drift and
partial because we will do it by
report to only one of the results
intermediaries j2x both the drift and of
gdx with respect to x we ​​will do the sum
of these drift products is there for
all the functions
geii intermediates of x example reasons
imagine the function eve 2x which
equal to 4 exponential points of
explodes three times a ce1 plus x at the 3
and now imagine that as
intermediate results as functions
intermediates identified g12 x as
being the exponential of x86
and then I have 2 x 2 fighters plus x
find here so we can write f 2 x
committing four times j 1 2x plus three
times I have 2 2x at the three is good with
the rule has diverged
everything I need to calculate a
eric's fault like that is the drift and
of fgx compared to June of 6 in derry
partial of f / 2 8 gx ratio drift
and of jr 2 x compared to x plus so
I'm multiplying my fingers together
in my bypass street h & m plus the
drift and fgx by barges and dx
of partial evry times the drift and doji of
drake with respect to x so the der screw of
f2 extra legal it had to leave
arsenic by gntx so that's
here I'm drifting and this
expression there just compared to 2.6 or
g2 extracts a constant
it just gives 4 actually
kind four times I indicate its derivative
of his c4 plus a term here that is a
constant which depends on gedo of aix but
which does not depend on embarrassment of x so that's me
gives partial lifts by vagina
to exploit 4 drift and June 2 x
I had an excellent exponential of x
so the beginning by paris
however that of the 2x dgf loaded with
partial dx by angers 2 2 x it'll be
so that of hervé compared to j-2 dx60
and more three times the grid of three
times I had xsara 3 so that's fine
give 3 x 3 to the 6 9 times g2x to the 3 - 1
so two kinds nine times g2x to
the adult and finally the der wiel of
gide or ex with respect to x kind the
derby 2-1 exquisite 0 more there reed
expo report to aix that is important to
give derby which is equal to medan with
the shange rule shange small
combined his whole people even four
times the exponential 2x found here
+ 9 times I have two at a time I had x
squared times a name done here I have a
mistake of having 2006 so more nine times
I have dxo square times a red has succeeded
but I do not need anything
is 1 something in question
so that gives me four of the experience
and the 2 x + 9 times I had to exki a +6
when we're here at the cable so it's a
example the derivation application in
chain that actually allows us to do
a drift and for expressions that
are arbitrarily complex and
finally see the concept of gradient in
does it's a concept that is very
simple so the gradient of a function f
that we want noted by a delta the reverse of
f
maybe it's just the vector
which will contain all the drifts and
partial of f
relative to each of these variables
input for example if we had the
function f xy previously planned
so they have fxy equals x squared
/ y
this is the first example we saw in
this capsule then the gradient of this
function there it's going to be the vector or the
first element is the deranged
partial of f2 xy with respect to x then
the second element is going to be the one of evry
partial of xy pupils compared to y
are and in this case we had
calculated that the partial derivatives by
report to and it was 2 x / y the hervé
partial compared to y it was less x
squared / so will be the gradian in
this case it's going to be a vector where
each of the elements is an expression
relative to our variables x and y is
so this function
this gradient designer is something
something that is going to be useful in fact for
analyze the variations over the
behavior of a function when
a function that contains more than one
variable in in the gradient in this
sector there is actually the information
on the variation of the function by
relation to each of our variables that
so departure our function